Hi, I'm Imani Hakim.
And I'm Ashly Burch.
And on Mythic Quest, we play
game testers.
What say you, Liliana the
Red? Ready to beat some ass?
But today we are giving some
other games a test.
Today we will find a champion.
Get ready for some high quality,
quality control.
♪♪
Testing for...
Bounciness and self-defense.
Something bad is gonna
happen.
Get back! (Laughs)
Get out of here, jerk.
(In unison)
7-8-9-10!
(Laughter)
This is what makes it all worth
it.
I say it's pretty fun.
Yeah. I'm bad at it, but I still
enjoyed myself.
Just trying is half the battle.
That's all you need.
Can you do tricks?
♪♪
Come on, Doggie.
-Ha.
♪♪
Mine is so disobedient. Bad dog.
-Okay, let's see.
This is like, isn't there a
around-the-world?
Yes.
-Type of thing.
You doing it.
It's happening.
-Is this around-the-world?
♪♪
Sigh...
Three points.
Fun rating?
-2.5.
-I agree with that.
I feel like it's got a good...
girth? (Laughs)
Uh...what?
I don't think the balls are the
problem, it's we are the
problem. -It's us. (Laughs)
Oh, don't be so modest. You guys
got the goods.
♪♪
Ashly:
Testing for?
Stackability.
-Very good.
Do they stack well?
Okay, okay, I get it.
♪♪
(Laughter)
Wait, there's one more.
I think they're a little small.
Ashly:
Too small.
-Yeah.
You want more...I was gonna say
girth again for the second
time.(Laughter)
♪♪
This one's pretty girthy.
-This one's pretty girthy.
Is there a proper way to do
this?
(Bouncing balloons)
That was weird, huh?
♪♪
Are you a good paper-footballer?
Yes. I'm gonna claim that..
-Ah!.
Ugh.
Ashly:
(Laughs)
-Apparently not.
Yah! Ah!
♪♪
Breathe.
-Fine.
It's good!
Oh, that was awesome man.
I think these games all kinda
have some bugs in them.
-Yeah
They suck.
They're not games.
They were fun, but not as fun as
Mythic Quest: Raven's Banquet.
Which you can watch right now.
It's streaming only on Apple
TV+.
Get ready for season 2!
-Woo!
Woo! (Laughter)
♪♪